got to be careful here this place is  crawling with all what was that  what cover me  guys hey guys hey guys oh thank god  and we started a community of survivors  y'all come live with us  [Music]  wait how did you know come on  redneck wants us to move into his  community us let's go  would you let me get your daughter  [Music]  my friends black and I love jay-z and my  favorite movie is Think Like a Man she's  good come with us stay close okay what's  your name Emily of course it is  no see what do you think about the  police  well let the third album I don't have  any money no money  [Music]  looking on oh my god thank God you guys  showed up I gotta get out of here it's a  silver Lexus just pull it right up front  and don't scuff the paint all right I  just had it buffed  was he an alien - yep  you